sigmar gabriel ehemaliger
bundeswirtschafts- und welt und
außenminister sowie vizekanzler aktuell
ist das spd-urgestein vorsitzender der
atlantik-brücke schirm guten morgen
guten morgen herr gabriel die meinungen
über den sinn und effekt von sanktionen
gehen auseinander was sagen sie an den
sanktionen fest reiten und sogar weiter
ausbauen
ob festhalten auf jeden fall ausbauen
muss man fragen wo das noch geht wenn
ein anderes land kommt und überfällt
sein nachbar staat dann haben sie drei
möglichkeiten zu reagieren die erste
möglichkeit ist sie tun gar nichts dann
ist das eine einladung dass der
weitermacht und vielleicht auch mal bei
ihnen vorbei schaut die zweite
möglichkeit ist die treten selbst in den
krieg ein um dieses land zu verteidigen
das wollten wir aus guten gründen nicht
weil die ukraine der nato nicht angehört
und weil wir keinen nuklearkrieg in
europa durch eine direkte konfrontation
usa russland produzieren wollten dann
haben sie nur noch eine möglichkeit und
das sind wirtschaftssanktionen und ich
glaube schon dass wenn der herbst kommt
und der winter kommt die auch in
russland bemerkt werden was kann was
sollte deutschland aber euch vielleicht
europa tun was sie eventuell politisch
und militärisch noch nicht auf dem
schirm haben haben sie eine idee
ich habe eine andere sorge wo wir
möglicherweise zu wenig tun es gibt
viele länder dieser erde vor allen
dingen im globalen süden die den krieg
nicht so beurteilen wie wir die darin
nicht die aggression russland sehen
sondern irgendwie so eine art
stellvertreterkrieg zwischen zwei alten
imperialisten den usa und russland und
die sagen und wir sind die leidtragenden
bei denen explodieren die energiepreise
auch weil deutschland als sehr reiches
land alles auf dem energiemarkt aufkauft
was da noch zu haben ist das treibt auch
die preise treibt diese länder in die
armut es gibt nahrungsmittelkrisen und
ich glaube was wir tun müssen ist diesen
ländern wie weit menschen helfen sonst
verlieren wir sozusagen die die
auseinandersetzung über die frage wer
ist hier eigentlich schuld am ende
schauen viele auf uns und auf die
amerikaner und geben uns mindestens so
ich wollte den russen an diesem krieg
das ist nicht die wahrheit aber diese
sichtweise setzt sich nach und nach
durch und das geht nur wenn wir diesen
ländern mehr helfen ich glaube da ist
die größte lücke die sich zurzeit
jedenfalls erkennen kann ich glaube
nicht dass wir heute ja dass sie jetzt
die abstimmung in den vereinten nationen
hätten noch mal 144 staaten auf unserer
seite hätten sie sprechen damit
natürlich auch länder wie südafrika und
co an vor allen dingen dann die
politische führung das ist ja hier bei
uns in deutschland definitiv anders die
bundesregierung hat eine relativ klare
linie aber bei den steigenden
energiepreisen der steigenden inflation
dann wird die bevölkerung hier bei uns
immer unzufriedener im herbst drohen
jetzt auch proteste immer mehr menschen
fragen sich ob der preis in deutschland
für diesen krieg zahlt nicht doch zu
hoch ist andere wiederum fordern dass
man jetzt nord stream zwei zulässt wie
sehen sie das
also ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
es viele menschen gibt in deutschland
die ungeheuer sorgenvoll in die zukunft
blicken denn eine verdrei vervierfachung
der energiepreise das bringt menschen
mit einem durchschnittlichen einkommen
schon an die grenze ihrer möglichkeiten
ich glaube dass es richtig ist dass
deshalb von der bundesregierung jede
maßnahme ergriffen wird die hilft diese
energiepreis explosionen zu dämpfen das
ist das vielleicht wichtigste was die
politik derzeit machen muss um die
gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten note 2 auf
zu machen wäre im ergebnis eine schwere
katastrophe für europa aber natürlich
die osteuropäer den deutschen vorwerfen
würden wir würden jetzt quasi den
ukrainer in den rücken fallen in dem wir
wieder handel mit russland anfangen man
könnte was anderes machen da steht ja
erdgas an
das kann ja nicht zurück nach russland
da steht in lublin ja sozusagen in der
röhre und wenn russland seine
vertraglichen verpflichtungen gegenüber
deutschland nicht erfüllt und das tut es
derzeit nicht weil alle möglichen schein
argumente vorgetragen werden warum der
gastransport tus nord stream einzig
ginge dann kann man überlegen ob die
europäer nicht gemeinschaftlich dieses
erdgas das in dieser röhre ist und nicht
zurückkehren beschlagnahmt und russland
verklagt auf nichts vertrags einhaltung
aber ich glaube nicht dass man einfach
nord stream zwei aufmachen kann und zu
tun als sei nichts passiert
interessanter gedanke sehen sie denn
eigentlich jetzt wird viel über den
krieg gesprochen und wie das eigentlich
weitergeht und ob es ein stellungskrieg
ist kommen wir mal spricht öffentlich
über frieden sehen sie noch frieden
durch verhandlungen wie auch immer das
mit einem aggressor gehen soll der
eigentlich ja nur die vernichtung der
ukraine will oder muss die ukraine
diesen krieg gewinnen
wann enten kriege entweder wenn einer
gewinnt oder wenn beide müde sind und
ausgelaugt und nicht mehr weiter machen
wollen beides ist nicht der fall weder
russland gewinnt noch die ukraine es ist
nach allen internationalen beobachten so
was wie einst el mate also diesen einen
abnutzungskrieg wo mal der eine mal der
andere ein bisschen fortschritte hat
aber wo sich nichts wirklich bewegt und
die ukraine ist ja wirklich heldenhaft
das kann man ja nicht anders sagen sie
zeigen uns westeuropäern ja gerade dass
wir nicht in post heroischen zeiten
sondern in der ukraine in erotischen
zeiten leben deswegen glaube ich nicht
dass russland die chance zu gewinnen
umgekehrt ist russland eine nuklearmacht
es ist schwer vorstellbar dass wir die
mehr putin mit seiner armee wieder aus
dem don was aus der krim vertrieben wird
und deswegen bleibt offensichtlich nur
die hoffnung dass irgendwann beide
seiten so müde sind das dann
verhandlungen möglich werden nur eins
ist doch klar wir werden ja von den
ukrainer nicht verlangen können mal eben
auf 20 prozent ihres territoriums zu
verzichten deswegen ist meine vermutung
dass dieser krieg noch ziemlich lange
andauern wird vielleicht gibt es mal ein
waffenstillstand ja geht der neue los
vielleicht wechselt das zu partisanen
auseinandersetzung aber ein echter
friede der ist glaube ich in sehr weiter
entfernung und wir werden einen neuen
eisernen vorhang bekommen zwischen der
ostsee und dem schwarzen meer viel
gefährlicher als der alte in zeiten von
cyber security und fehlkalkulation also
das sind schon
schwierige zeiten auf die wir da zu
laufen vor allen dingen auch für die
menschen in der ukraine vielen dank
sigmar gabriel für das gespräch heute
aktuell der vorsitzende der
atlantik-brücke alles gute
gerne ihn auch